[Musique]
Ivan qu'elle est jolie la fille d'en
bas chapeau de paille et là
basudoir quand elle va comment ça va
qu'elle est jolie cette larme
là on vit sa vie mais on ne sait
pas où va la vie quand l'amour est
là on fait son lit sous les lit
là on dit
toujours mais ça ne tient
pas qu'elle est jolie cette larme
là vaille que vaille elle pense à moi
quand elle vient plus rien ne
va qu'elle est jolie la fille d'en
[Musique]
bas on vit sa vie on compte sur tout
drôle de vie il y en a pas
beaucoup on fait son lit sous les
lilas on dit qu'un jour mais ça ne vient
pas qu'elle est jolie la fille d'en
bas chapeau de paille et la B
doigt quand elle va
comment ça
va qu'elle est jolie cette larme
là le vent debout lui fait les yeux
doux et je l'ai vu se pendre à son
cou re légèr et B de
soi
qu'elle est
jolie la fille
[Musique]
d'enas